bonjour à tous
neuf millions de ménages utilisent des
crédits à la consommation c'est pour
limiter les abus et protéger les
consommateurs que le sénat se penche à
nouveau cet après midi sur ce projet de
loi relatifs aux crédits à la
consommation l'objectif est de mieux
informer les consommateurs et de
responsabiliser les acteurs
principalement les banques fortement
pointé du doigt est victime de
l'embouteillage parlementaire un an
s'est écoulé entre les deux lecture de
ce texte à la haute assemblée le sénat à
qui a enrichi le texte il a notamment
introduit le principe de la création
d'un registre des crédits qui
permettrait de recenser les crédits des
neuf millions de français
un principe condamnée par les
associations de consommateurs qui y
voient une atteinte aux libertés
individuelles mais un principe repris ce
matin par christine lagarde qui a
annoncé sa demande de rapport sur la
création de ce fichier
autre apport du sénat le traitement du
surendettement
avec la crise le nombre de surendettés a
augmenté de 17% en 2009
franchissant le cap des 200 milles le
sénat a donc introduit des mesures
permettant un meilleur suivi des
surendettés est tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle poursuivre l'examen de ce
texte en présence de la ministre de
l'économie christine lagarde est très
bonne séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
deuxième lecture du projet de loi
modifié par l'assemblée nationale
portant réforme du crédit à la
consommation
madame briques pour un rappel au
règlement
merci madame la présidente je fonde mon
rappel au règlement
sur l'article 48 alinéa 6 qui traite de
la recevabilité des amendements et qui
au nom d'une jurisprudence ou demeurant
récente du conseil constitutionnel dit
pratique de l'entonnoir permet
permettrait en tout cas d'évacuer des
amendements qui serait irrecevable
avec aussi une causalité qui n'auraient
pas de lien direct avec le texte nous
avons eu ce débat en commission et comme
je voudrais je ne voudrais pas que la
pratique qui consiste à déclarer
irrecevables des amendements au titre de
cet alinéa de l'article 48 créer un
précédent pour la suite et comme je sais
qu'un groupe de travail de notre sénat
est chargé d'examiner l'application du
règlement intérieur tel qu'il a été
modifié à la suite de la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008
je souhaiterais que l'on me donne
lecture des cas qui ont déjà relevé de
cette jurisprudence interne car un
certain nombre d'amendements que le
groupe socialiste avait déposé ont été
déclarés à ce titre là irrecevables et
notamment un auquel nous tenons beaucoup
qui venait à qui est l amendement numéro
donc
je voudrais protesté au nom de mon
groupe sur cette pratique qui restreint
le débat parlementaire je sais bien que
le sénat comme le l'assemblée il y
aurait ce depuis quelque temps le
gouvernement nous a habitués à ce que
nous n'ayons qu'une lecture dite
accélérée
l'ancienne procédure d'urgence et que
donc le cas se pose moins puisqu'il
s'agit de la deuxième lecture
mais c'est une restriction du débat
parlementaire en séance qui nous permet
d'argumenter qui est exercée à notre
endroit
donc je voudrais avoir une clarification
sur ce point du règlement intérieur
oui macha collègues je vous signale et
vous le savez sûrement très bien car
article 8 la commission qui a été saisie
au fond et compétente pour se prononcer
sur la recevabilité des amants et
sous-amendement dans les cas prévus au
présent article monsieur je demande je
donne la parole à monsieur mailly oui
madame la présidente
en quelques mots je voudrais dire à nos
collègues que la commission a débattu de
la recevabilité de cinq amendements
déposés par madame nicole bricq et les
membres du groupe socialiste
nous avons admis la recevabilité de
trois d'entre eux mais nous avons
déclaré irrecevables deux de ces
amendements
nous nous fondons en effet sur l'alinéa
6 dernière phrase de l'article 48 du
règlement du sénat est irrecevable toute
modification ou adjonction cenc relation
directe avec une dispositions restant en
discussion
nous nous sommes fondés sur plusieurs
précédents s'agissant en effet d'une
nouvelle compétence de la commission
saisie au fond et
le premier cas d'application est
probablement intervenue dans le cadre de
la loi sur le grenelle de
l'environnement
et c'est à ce moment-là que lors de sa
réunion du 30 juin 2009 la commission de
l'économie avait déclaré irrecevable
cinq amendements et pour absence de
relation directe avec les dispositions
restant en discussion
alors c'était respectivement des
amendements présentés par notre collègue
jacques blanc notre collègue evelyne
didier notre collègue francis grignon
notre collègue daniel raoul
et il s'agissait dans deux cas seulement
d'articles additionnels de même avait
été déclaré recevoir pour les mêmes
raisons un amendement présenté par
madame odette herviaux et compte tenu de
cette de cette première décision de
principe prise par la commission de
l'économie et le
président roland du luart avait fait une
déclaration en séance le 1er juillet
2009 et il avait notamment conclu en
disant en conséquence sont en principe
est recevable et amendement remettant en
cause les conformes ou ceux qui sont
sans relation directe avec les relations
avec les dispositions restant en
discussion
et pour ce qui nous concerne nous avons
souhaité en rester à l'interprétation la
plus littérale possible du règlement
madame la présidente
c'est à dire que nous avons cherché à
apprécier le caractère de relations
directes ou de non relation directe avec
une dispositions restant en discussion
et c'est en vertu de de ceux de ce
critère que nous avons donc partagés
le bloc de cinq amendements est rendu ce
que je n'ose qualifier de jugement de
salomon
merci monsieur le président vous avez
répondu à madame briques sur ce point
précis elle y reviendra sûrement dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à mme lam christine
lagarde ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie et de l'emploi
alors la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis heureuse
aujourd'hui de dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs car il y a une
belle représentation de nos deux genres
le crédit à la consommation est
largement utilisé vous le savez
largement décrié aussi aujourd'hui ce ne
sont pas moins de neuf millions de nos
concitoyens qui utilisent le crédit à la
consommation sont également 2,6 millions
de nos concitoyens qui se trouvent en
difficulté de remboursement et nous le
savons ne surendettement a
considérablement augmenté au cours des
derniers mois puisque le nombre de
surendettés actuellement à 750 mille
ménages a augmenté d'environ 15% entre
septembre 2008 et septembre 2009
les derniers chiffres dont nous
disposions actuellement donc ce texte
qui revient devant votre vote assemblée
est un texte déterminant indispensable
et qui doit permettre de trouver un
juste équilibre entre l'impératif de
crédit à la consommation puisque 9
millions de nos concitoyens en ont
besoin et que cette année instruments de
gestion de la consommation utile et
efficace et que par ailleurs nous devons
en limiter les excès en limiter les abus
et éviter les situations de faiblesses
dans lesquelles se trouvent parfois
certains de nos concitoyens
j'ai toujours eu personnellement la
conviction que le régulateur devait
intervenir en la matière et qu' il était
de notre devoir de protéger dans un
certain nombre de cas le consommateur de
crédits surtout celui qui se trouve en
vulnérabilités je ne vais pas m'étendre
très longuement sur toutes les mesures
du projet de loi que vous connaissez
bien
ce projet je les dis doit beaucoup à
votre haute assemblée qui a contribué à
certaines de ces mesures les plus fortes
je pense notamment à la réforme de
l'usure et au choix donner aux
consommateurs en magasin entre crédit
amortissable et crédit renouvelable et
je tiens à cet égard a salué le travail
remarquable effectué sous votre autorité
monsieur le rapporteur général président
de la commission spéciale et à la
qualité des travaux et des analyses
effectuées par votre rapporteur
monsieur le sénateur philippe dominati
alors au moment où nous approchons de la
fin de ces travaux dont je ferai
remarquer qu'ils n'ont pas été assortie
de l'urgence et qu'ils ont par
conséquent donner libre cours à
l'ensemble des débats à la fois devant
votre haute assemblée et devant
l'assemblée nationale et ils ont été
enrichis par les contributions de votre
assemblée
eh bien je suis convaincu que ce texte
va changer la vie des consommateurs dans
leur consommation et dans leurs
habitudes de crédit et je voudrais
simplement vous engager à ce que nous
suivions pratiquement un consommateur
dans son périple
lorsqu'il s'agit donc d'obtenir du
crédit à la consommation et ensuite d'en
subir les vicissitudes ou de bénéficier
des changements qu'apportera votre texte
c'est donc sur le triptyque de
l'accompagnement des consommateurs de
l'accompagnement des personnes
surendettées et enfin du microcrédit que
je voudrais rapidement revenir sur ce
texte qu'on a l'impression de bien
connaître tente on l'a déjà beaucoup lui
ai beaucoup travaillé et qui bien
souvent nous réserve encore parfois
quelques uns quelques surprises alors
c'est évidemment d'abord par la
publicité que le consommateur entre en
contact avec le crédit consommation
cette publicité qui inondent les
magazines qui n'ont nos boîtes mails nos
téléphones portables tapageuse agressive
parfois trompeuses souvent harcelante ce
projet de loi propose de mettre fin aux
réclames trop agressive en encadrant la
publicité est il interdit notamment les
mentions qui suggère qu'un crédit
améliore la situation financière de
l'emprunteur
il propose d'appeler un chat un chat les
publicités devront parler de crédit
renouvelable à l'exclusion de toute
autre expression que nous voyons
ici ou là il propose de faire la lumière
sur le coût des crédits
le vrai taux des crédits à la
consommation devra dorénavant dorénavant
figurer aussi clairement que les taux
promotionnels temporaire par hypothèse
qui sont utilisés pour attirer le client
voici maintenant notre consommateur
entrant dans un magasin il son regard
est accroché par une magnifique
pancartes qui lui promet 10 % de
réduction sur tous les produits du
magasin pour les détenteurs de la carte
de fidélité bien sûr enthousiaste mais
probablement un peu insouciant notre
consommateur souscrite immédiatement au
programme de fidélité
l'enseigne a malencontreusement oublié
d'assister sur le fait qu'un crédit
renouvelable est attaché à la carte de
fidélité et le programme de fidélité
devient le cheval de troie du crédit
cette méthode serait sans conséquence si
notre consommateur ne recevait pas en
fin de mois un courrier lui précisant
qu'il doit dans les cinq jours
réglées par chèque les achats du mois
passé faute de quoi les sommes
incriminées seront automatiquement
débités sur son crédit renouvelable et
pour peu que notre consommateur oublie
d'ouvrir son courrier en fin de mois eh
bien le voilà entrés à l'insu de son
plein gré si j'ose dire en crédit
renouvelable le projet de loi propose de
renverser le système
j'ai voulu que les cartes de fidélité
disposez impérativement d'une fonction
comptant activée en priorité avec cette
fois le consommateur insouciant qui
s'endort au volant de sa carte de
fidélité tombera dans le paiement
comptant et non plus en crédit comme
aujourd'hui et le projet de loi précise
qu'il est interdit de conditionner des
avantages commerciaux à l' usage à
crédit de la carte avec 7,4 consommateur
sera fidèle au paiement comptant et non
acculé au crédit à son insu puis voilà
un autre consommateur dans ce même
magasin qui se dirige vers un vendeur
pour demander s'il serait possible de
financer son achat par un crédit à la
consommation que le consommateur achète
alors un home cinéma
une cuisine ou de quoi rénover son
logement
la réponse est invariablement la même on
vous
oppose un crédit renouvelable qu'il
s'agisse donc de l'investissement d'une
vie ou d'une menues dépenses
les enseignes ne propose aujourd'hui que
un seul type de crédit du crédit
renouvelable alors notre consommateurs
voulaient financé par un crédit ponctuel
un achats ponctuels et le voilà avec le
fil à la patte d'un crédit renouvelable
sous l'impulsion de votre rapporteur le
sénateur philippe dominati votre haute
assemblée a adopté en première lecture
une mesure forte qui redonne du choix
aux consommateurs puisque pour les
achats de plus de 1000 euros il oblige
les magasins à proposer le choix entre
soit crédit amortissable soit crédits
renouvelables l'efficacité de cette
mesure est renforcé par la réforme des
taux d'usure voulue par votre président
philippe marini qui remettent à pied
d'égalité crédit amortissable et crédit
renouvelable grâce à des modes de
détermination du taux qui ne seront plus
fondée sur la nature juridique et du
contrat mais tout simplement sur les
montants concernés faut pas accabler les
vendeurs de crédit me direz vous il est
possible qu'un système de commissions
les incite à vendre du crédit
renouvelable plutôt qu'à morty sable
mais oui mais c'est l'histoire que je
vous raconte exactement madame brics et
la réalité d'aujourd'hui
l'espoir d'un choix du consommateur ne
serait alors qu'une façade
au contraire la loi que vous allez
examiner le projet de golf vous allez
examiner interdira de différencier le
commissionnement des vendeurs à crédit
entre vendeurs à crédit renouvelable et
vendeurs à crédit amortissable notre
consommateur a maintenant finalement
décidé de souscrire un crédit avec
quelle facilité l'autoroute du crédit
est sans panneaux de signalisation des
limitations de vitesse vous pouvez
aujourd'hui entrer en crédit sans
qu'elle était évaluée
les revenus ou l'endettement au crédit
sans sécurité d'aujourd'hui le projet de
loi mme oppose un crédit vraiment
responsable il oblige le prêteur a
vérifié la solvabilité du client et j'ai
bien dit vérifier ce qu'ils
participaient à ces débats s'en
souviennent nous avons débattu de la
vertu de la vérification
c'est bien sûr ce moment là que nous
nous sommes arrêtés
il oblige donc à vérifier
et c'était je crois sous l'instigation
de madame la sénateure muguette dini
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales que nous avions je vous ai fait
le choix de ce terme vérifier et qui
finalement a trouvé donc son chemin dans
le projet de loi la loi oblige également
le prêteur à consulter le fichier des
incidents de paiement
il s'agit là d'une demande récurrente du
médiateur de la république jean-paul
delevoye
il a demandé depuis de nombreuses années
depuis de nombreux rapports et c'est
donc une obligation qui est mise à la
charge des banques
la loi oblige enfin le prêteur et le
conservateur c'est la troisième
obligation supplémentaire à la charge
des banques en obligations donc de
vérifier la solvabilité obligation de
consulter le fichier et fils ep
troisième obligation c'est celle que
j'ai appelé l'obligation à 80 qui oblige
le prêteur et l'emprunteur à remplir une
fiche de dialogue sur les revenus et
l'endettement du consommateur pour faire
le point sur son budget et ses capacités
de remboursement pour plus de sécurité
la loi exige d'ailleurs des
consommateurs qu'ils remettent aux
prêteurs des justificatifs pour les gros
crédit voilà notre consommateur entrer
en crédit
mais pour combien de temps chacun
d'entre vous connaît dans sa
circonscription parmi ses proches
l'exemple d'un emprunteur en crédits
renouvelables qui a mis 15 ans à
rembourser un réfrigérateur
l'astuce est connue si la mensualité est
trop faible
les intérêts ils prennent toute la place
et le capital ne se rembourse pas le
projet de loi met fin aux crédits qui ne
se remboursent jamais il impose à chaque
mensualité sur un crédit renouvelable de
contenir un amortissement minimum de
capital
les crédits de moins de 3000 euros
devront se rembourser en moins de trois
ans les autres supérieur à 3000 euros
devront se rembourser en moins de cinq
années voilà un autre consommateur
équipé d'un crédit renouvelable souscrit
il ya plusieurs années
depuis il a connu un accident de la vie
perte d'emploi divorce comme les trois
quarts des huit cent mille ménages qui
connaissent une situation de
surendettement actuellement
la crise a mis tous les budgets sous
tension et la tentation peut être forte
de tirer sur un crédit renouvelable qui
ne ferait qu aggraver sa situation
d'endettement et aujourd'hui rien
n'empêche la fuite en avant
la loi prévoit désormais un rendez vous
annuel de solvabilité qui oblige les
banques à vérifier des éléments de
solvabilité pour suspendre la réserve de
crédit
si la situation du consommateur s'est
détériorée mais me direz-vous tous les
rendez-vous du monde et toutes les
obligations de la terre n'empêcheront
pas les accidents les dépôts de dossiers
de surendettement je le disais tout à
l'heure on peut augmenter de 15% en un
an et c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu que dans
ce projet de loi on trouve également un
certain nombre de mesures pour lutter
contre le surendettement et essayer de
le prévenir
la solution face à des difficultés
d'endettement peut être parfois on le
sait de faire appel à des rachats de
crédits un certain nombre d'officines
sont en train de se spécialiser dans
cette matière
parce qu'on pense qu'il vaut mieux
peut-être un gros crédit dont on
connaîtra les mensualités de
remboursement qu'une multitude de petits
crédits dans lesquels on ne s'y retrouve
pas ces rachats sont à encourager à la
condition qu'ils soient vraiment
responsables
le projet de loi propose d'encadrer les
rachats de crédits pour les rendre plus
transparents et la loi prévoit que la
banque qui rachètera des crédits à
l'obligation de proposer aux
consommateurs d'effectuer pour son
compte toutes les démarches pour fermer
les crédits antérieurs
quand on prend la peine de regrouper des
crédits soyons responsables et veillant
à ce que les anciennes réserve de crédit
puissent être régulièrement close sinon
on risque de se retrouver avec des
crédits rachetés
mais avec un certain nombre de réserves
qui sont encore en activité vue pour
certains le rachat de crédit n'y
changera rien non plus et le
consommateur dépose alors un dossier en
commission de surendettement
actuellement si les propriétaires de sa
résidence
la porte de la commission de
surendettement lui est parfois fermé les
assises régionales du surendettement que
j'avais demandé à la banque de france
d'organiser en juin 2009 l'ont
clairement démontré dans certaines
régions c'est la pratique des
commissions de surendettement que
d'exclure du bénéfice de la commission
les ménages surendettés dès lors qu'ils
seraient propriétaires de leur logement
j'ai voulu que la commission de
surendettement soit taxée
cible à tous parce qu'être propriétaire
ça n'est pas nécessairement une raison
suffisante pour n'avoir aucun recours
quand on connaît de vraies difficultés
et quand on sait que la vente du
domicile n'est pas forcément la solution
à la situation
le consommateur entre maintenant en
procédure de surendettement et cette
procédure doit être le temps de
l'accompagnement pour résoudre les
difficultés d'endettement est évidemment
pas le temps du harcèlement or on le
sait actuellement
dès lors qu'un ménage dépose un dossier
il est bien souvent harcelés par des
sociétés de recouvrement diverses et
variées par des huissiers qui évidemment
font tous leurs efforts au dernier
moment dans la dernière ligne droite
pour essayer de recouvrer les sommes qui
sont recouvrables le projet de loi
propose de suspendre les procédures de
saisie-exécution engagées par les
créanciers dès la recevabilité du
dossier
puis le temps de la procédure est aussi
bien souvent le temps de l'incertitude
difficile de se remettre en selle
difficile de rechercher un emploi quand
on ne sait pas de quoi demain sera fait
le projet de loi propose de diviser par
trois la durée les procédures de
rétablissement personnel ces procédures
qui actuellement dure à peu près un an
et demi dont on propose qu'elles
puissent être ramenée à six mois il faut
que les choses aillent vite pour aider
les personnes qui connaissent des
difficultés d'endettement à rebondir
aujourd'hui une personne qui est en plan
de surendettement est inscrite au
fichier affi cp des indices des
incidents de remboursement pendant une
période de 10 ans pendant toute cette
période la personne fichée aura beaucoup
de difficultés pour souscrire un crédit
et même parfois des difficultés dans les
relations dans les relations avec sa
banque pour faciliter le rebond des
personnes en difficulté le projet de loi
propose de diviser par deux la durée du
fichage on passe donc de dix ans à 5 ans
il réduit également de 10 ans à 8 ans la
durée des plans de surendettement
voilà ce que ce projet de loi largement
enrichie par vos contributions permet de
régler à la fois concernant le
consommateur celui qui entre en crédit
consommation de manière plus éclairées
avec des choix plus plus large
avec un amortissement systématique sans
être la victime de la carte de fidélité
cheval de troie et puis ce sont toutes
les mesures relatives au surendettement
qui sont déterminantes et dont il faut
impérativement qu'elle puisse entrer en
oeuvre rapidement
dernier volet de ce projet de loi
importants lui aussi auquel vous êtes
monsieur le président de la commission
spéciale vous aussi extrêmement attachés
c'est tout le dispositif concernant le
microcrédit dont on sait pertinemment
qu'il est utile qu'il est utilisé et
qu'il permet un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens qui veulent démarrer une
activité bien il leur permet tout
simplement de remettre le pied à
l'étrier
cet outil de financement dont on sait
qu'il est efficace et est largement
disponible pour financer des initiatives
de microcrédit hors du territoire
français grâce à notre projet de loi est
bien dorénavant nous pourrons développer
également ses activités de microcrédit
sur le territoire français vous savez
que par ailleurs les banques françaises
ont annoncé le 25 janvier une initiative
pour développer le microcrédit et afin
de suivre l'efficacité de cette
initiative
la loi prévoit que les banques publient
chaque année un bilan de leurs activités
dans ce domaine
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur
ce projet de loi nous éloigne peut-être
un peu des préoccupations du moment
mais il nous plonge au plus près des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens à ce
qui fait leur quotidien as qui fait
parfois leurs difficultés du quotidien
et je crois que à cet égard eh bien il
est extrêmement utile et j'espère
vivement que nous puissions progresser
rapidement sur la mise en oeuvre de ce
projet de loi je vous avais indiqué que
je m'efforcerai d'être rapide dans la
mise en oeuvre du projet de loi elle
avait évoqué devant votre commission
spéciale mais c'est le président et je
m'engage à ce que les 14 décrets les
quatre arrêtés qui seront nécessaires à
la mise en oeuvre de ce projet de loi si
vous le voter soit pris avant la fin de
l'année 2010 et j'ai un calendrier de
mise en oeuvre de 10 des différents
blocs de législation que vous serez
amené à examiner aujourd'hui afin que le
plus vite possible les mesures en
matière de publicité
les mesures en matière de
surendettement et enfin les mesures en
matière de modification en profondeur du
crédit à la consommation puisse entrer
dans notre arsenal législatif et surtout
qu'ils puissent bénéficier à nos
concitoyens le plus rapidement possible
je vous remercie
merci madame ministre la parole est à
monsieur philippe dominati rapporteur de
la commission spéciale crédit à la
consommation madame la présidente madame
le président madame le ministre mes
chers collègues
c'est une appréciation le 17 juin 2009
il y a donc à peine plus d'un an le
sénat examiner le projet de loi portant
réforme du crédit à la consommation en
première lecture en séance publique nous
avait occupé deux jours entiers et après
un important travail de commission sous
le présidence éclairée et bienveillante
de philippe marini que je souhaite dès à
présent remercier nos réunions et nos
discussions avec l'ensemble des membres
de la commission spéciale avait en effet
été très constructifs en commission nous
avions procédé à plusieurs dizaines
d'auditions et examinait 103 amendements
dont les deux tiers ont été adoptés
tous les groupes composant notre
assemblée ont contribué à l'élaboration
du texte que nous avons ensuite débattu
en séance publique dans ce deuxième
temps 17 amendements supplémentaires ont
été adoptés sur les 121 déposée par
l'ensemble de ces groupes
l'encombrement du calendrier législatif
a malheureusement empêché l'assemblée
nationale d'examiner plus rapidement le
texte que nous lui avions transmis
malgré l'importance qu'elle a tout de
suite attaché à son objet pas moins de
quatre commissions
si on saisit se sont saisis du projet de
loi la commission des affaires
économiques sur le fond les commissions
des affaires sociales
d
finances et des lois pour avis elles ont
rendu leur rapport en décembre la
science publique s'est déroulée en
plusieurs phases
elle a commencé fin mars et s'est
achevée par un vote solennel sur le
texte adopté par les députés le 27 avril
aujourd'hui nous entamons une nouvelle
étape celle de la deuxième lecture du
projet de loi
nous avions transmis 50 un article à
l'assemblée nationale elle en a adopté
cinq conforme modifié 46 et ajouté 12
notre commission spéciale a donc eu 58
articles à examiner
alors que je vous le rappelle le projet
initial en comporter 34
celui ci a pratiquement doublé de taille
au cours de la navette parlementaire
dans ses grandes lignes le texte qui
nous revient de l'assemblée n'est pas
très différent de celui que nous avons
voté en première lecture
et c'est pour nous une source de grande
satisfaction cela montre la qualité du
travail effectué par notre commission
spéciale pour faire émerger des
solutions adaptées et aboutir à un
compromis que je dois que je crois
réellement équilibrée
celui ci a d'ailleurs recueilli
l'assentiment de nos collègues députés
qui ont reconnu je cite l'apport
substantiel du sénat au projet de loi
ainsi que l'affirmé françois loos le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques de l'assemblée nationale
saisie au fond vous le savez notre
assemblée s'est mobilisée depuis
longtemps sur ces questions du crédit à
la consommation et de la prévention du
surendettement
les cinq propositions de loi déposé peu
avant le projet de loi qui en était un
parfait témoignage tous leurs auteurs
notre président philippe marini claude
biver et les membres de son groupe
charles revêt et plusieurs de ses
collègues nicole bricq et les membres du
groupe socialiste michel davy fier et
les membres du groupe centriste ont
d'ailleurs largement contribué à
l'élaboration du texte issu des travaux
du sénat
je voudrais donc une nouvelle fois salué
ici leur engagement car il s'agit
assurément d'un sujet
essentiel parfois même critique pour
nombre de nos concitoyens
la crise que nous connaissons depuis 18
mois maintenant à bien entendu encore
accentué les difficultés que les uns et
les autres avions clairement perçu et
souhaitait corriger
je voudrais également rendre hommage à
madame le ministre madame la ministre de
l'économie
nous savons quel a été votre implication
sur ce dossier et nous vous en sommes
gré votre ténacité et la mobilisation de
nouveaux services mais surtout les veaux
arbitrage ondes une très large part
permis les avancées que nous voulons en
taurine et aujourd'hui vous vous en
souvenez le projet de loi initial
poursuivez de plusieurs objectifs en
premier lieu transposer la directive
communautaire du 23 avril 2008 sur le
crédit aux consommateurs mais il était
en réalité bien plus ambitieux car les
leviers d'une part à réduire le mal
endettement notamment en diminuant la
part du crédit renouvelable au profit du
crédit amortissable
d'autre part à améliorer les procédures
de traitement de surendettement en
première lecture nous avions estimé que
le projet de loi était un bon texte et
qu'il nécessitait quelques compléments
pour comporter effectivement toute la
gamme des outils lui permettant de
donner sa pleine mesure
c'est pourquoi nous avions introduit
trois dispositions entièrement nouvelle
que nous jugions majeures relatives
respectivement à la réforme du taux de
l'usure au principe de la création d'un
fichier positif au renforcement du
microcrédit premier ajout la réforme des
seuils de l'usure
il nous avait semblé indispensable de
revoir la législation actuelle ma
position initiale était que dans une
économie moderne
la régulation doit venir du marché sous
le contrôle des organes chargés à
veillez au respect des règles de la
concurrence
et s'agissant des intérêts individuels
sous le contrôle du juge
une telle situation se retrouve
d'ailleurs dans la plupart des pays
voisins
cela signifiait donc la suppression du
régime de l'usure nous avons toutefois
estimé que le contexte est l'opinion
n'était pas encore prêt et avant donc
retenu une solution intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire la fixation des taux en
raison non pas de la catégorie du
produit mais du montant du produit
à cet effet nous avons d'une part donner
une base législative à cette
transformation
d'autre part autorisé une gestion
administrée des taux sur une période
maximale de deux ans afin que le
changement de règle ne conduisent pas à
l'effondrement brutal du marché du
crédit
enfin nous avons institué un comité
ad-hoc pour superviser la réforme et
vérifier les conditions de constitution
des marges des établissements de crédit
l'assemblée nationale a adopté sans
modification cette réforme du taux de
l'usure qui figure à l'article 1a du
projet de loi
deuxième ajout le fichier positif
nous avons eu de nombreux débats sur ce
sujet nous avons entendu des avis très
variés effectué un déplacement en
belgique pour approfondir la question
à titre personnel comme plusieurs
d'entre vous d'ailleurs vous vous en
souvenez je n'étais pas absolument
convaincu de l'efficacité de cet outil
pour la lutte contre le surendettement
notre commission spéciale avait
néanmoins trouver une solution de
compromis en posant le principe de la
création d'un fichier positif à terme
mais en donnant un peu de temps à
l'évaluation notamment des effets de la
présente loi à la concertation pour
permettre de rapprocher suffisamment les
points de vue entre les parties encore
très divisé et à la réflexion sur ce
qu'on veut vraiment faire de cet outil
et comment l'utiliser
l'assemblée nationale a de son côté
également approuvé le principe d'une
réflexion sur la mise en place d'un
fichier positif les débats ayant été
vifs entre partisans et adversaires de
la mise en place d'un tel fichier
l'accord final s'est fait autour d'un
amendement du gouvernement qui lui aussi
n'était pas très favorable départ a
évolué dans ses positions
cette disposition adoptée à une large
majorité prévoit un rapport sur la
création et non plus sur le seul
principe ou l'opportunité de la création
d'un registre national des crédits aux
particuliers
ce rapport sera remis au gouvernement au
parlement dans le délai de un an à
compter de la promulgation de la loi le
sénat avait adopté je vous le rappelle
un délai de trois ans
un comité chargé de préfigurer cette
création et dont la composition sera
fixé par décret à la responsabilité de
la de l'élaboration de rapports en
séance devant les députés madame lagarde
a donné des indications plus précises
sur cette composition en insistant sur
son caractère mixte
le comité devant représenter l'ensemble
des parties prenantes notamment les
associations de consommateurs pour notre
part vous vous en souvenez nous avions
confié l'élaboration du rapport à la
commission chargée d'évaluer la loi que
nous avons créée à l'article 33 du
projet de loi
le travail de compromis sur cette
question importante s'est donc
poursuivie à l'assemblée nationale
rapprochant les positions des uns et des
autres y compris celle du gouvernement
3e âge joue le microcrédit social
plusieurs auditions avaient montré la
nécessité de procéder à une nouvelle
définition du microcrédit personnel en
le centrant sur sa finalité sociale afin
d'en faire un soutien au maintien et au
retour vers l'emploi
ainsi qu'à tout projet d'insertion
sociale il nous avait aussi semblait
important de mettre au fond de permettre
au fonds de cohésion sociale de financer
non seulement les garanties mais aussi
directement les dépenses
d'accompagnement des bénéficiaires
l'assemblée nationale nous a suivis elle
a même complété le dispositif avait afin
d'en écarter aucune piste d'intérêt
social pour la relance du microcrédit
personnel
sur le reste du texte les députés ont
très largement maintenu les
enrichissements apportés par le sénat
aux dispositions initiales qui
s'orientait pour l'essentiel dans quatre
directions
la première renforcer l'information et
la protection des consommateurs
notamment en précisant certaines
modalités relatives à la publicité en
faisant en sorte que la fiche de
dialogue puisse être accompagné des
justificatifs nécessaires
notre deuxième priorité était de
clarifier la relation entre le commerce
et le crédit sion à cet effet nous avons
assuré une meilleure confidentialité des
opérations sur le lieu de vente garanti
la formation des personnels concernés
permis un contrôle facilité du respect
de ces prescriptions par l'autorité
administrative
nous avons également fait en sorte que
le consommateur qui désire régler à
crédit d achat dépasse une certaine
somme dépassant une certaine somme
puisse disposer systématiquement d'une
offre alternative de crédit amortissable
lorsqu'on lui soumet une offre de crédit
renouvelable soutenir le crédit
personnel plutôt que le crédit
renouvelable était notre troisième
orientation en facilitant notamment
l'application de la loi chatel sur la
résiliation de fils d'un crédit
renouvelable non utilisés enfin dernière
priorité améliorer le fonctionnement de
la procédure liées au surendettement et
aux effets icp nous avons cherché à
mieux harmoniser les pratiques
développées un suivi social plus étroit
des personnes surendettées et compléter
les règles de fonctionnement du fcp dans
un sens plus favorable aux emprunteurs
de son côté l'assemblée nationale a elle
aussi continuer à enrichir le texte en
proposant un réexamen régulier de la
solvabilité des emprunteurs ayant
souscrit un crédit renouvelable à
travers une consultation annuelle du
déficit paix et un examen complet de la
solvabilité tous les trois ans
un renforcement de la transparence de
l'offre assurantielle avec une
information sur son cou dans la
publicité et l'offre de contrat et pour
les crédits immobiliers
l'obligation de motiver les décisions de
refus de délégation d'assurance
un meilleur fonctionnement de l'actuel
et fils ip par l'ostau par
l'instauration d'un mécanisme d' alerte
préventive une meilleure protection des
débiteurs contre les mesures d'expulsion
susceptibles d'être prononcées à leur
égard dès lors que leur dossier a été
jugé recevable
plusieurs amendements du gouvernement
ont également été adoptées par les
députés en particulier pour tirer les
conséquences du rapport de madame cohen
branche magistrat à la cour de cassation
missionné par la ministre de l'économie
sur les relations entre les banques et
les personnes surendettées
ce rapport est en cours d'achèvement
mais le gouvernement a souhaité d'ores
et déjà mettre en oeuvre certaines des
conclusions auxquelles il parvient une
réforme de l'institut national de la
consommation a enfin été approuvé sur
les sur la base des préconisations des
assises de la consommation tenue à la
fin du mois d'octobre dernier
l'ensemble du texte qui résulte des
travaux ainsi décrit assemblée à notre
commission spéciale très largement
correspondrait ce que nous avions
souhaité faire de ce projet de loi en
première lecture
je le redis le compris le compromis que
nous avions trouvé entre les positions
et souhaits exprimés par les différentes
parties concernées et équilibrée
l'absence d' amendements en commission
traduit bien à mon sens cet équilibre
c'est pourquoi notre commission a décidé
d'adopter sans modification le texte qui
nous vient de l'assemblée nationale nous
avons estimé que cela permettra à la
fois une application sans trop tarder
d'un projet de loi attendu par beaucoup
est presque respecté les délais de
transposition de la directive européenne
celle ci a en effet prévu la date limite
du 12 mai 2010 pour sa traduction en
droit interne
la plupart des parties intéressées par
ce projet de loi nous ont d'ailleurs
signifié que le texte élaboré par le
sénat d'abord puis l'assemblée nationale
représentait un équilibre raisonnable
nombre d'entre elles ont d'ores et déjà
anticiper cibler certaines dispositions
du texte ce qui est naturellement très
satisfaisant par exemple dans les
publicités où les notices d'information
remise aux consommateurs et aux
emprunteurs
si l'entrée en vigueur rapide de ce
projet de loi nous paraît donc
aujourd'hui prioritaire
elle n'en signifie pas moins que nous
resterons vigilants sur son application
et n'hésiteront pas à en corriger
certaines dispositions si cela devait
s'avérer nécessaire
nous avons eu l'ambition de faire oeuvre
utile sur un sujet essentiel pour la vie
de nos concitoyens
il est important que cette ambition soit
pleinement mises en oeuvre
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci à chaque collègue
la parole est à monsieur philippe marini
président de la commission spéciale
crédit à la consommation
le président madame le ministre mes
chers collègues
quelques brèves remarques si vous le
permettez avant que le débat ne
s'ouvrent aux orateurs des groupes
tout d'abord pour féliciter et remercier
notre excellent rapporteur philippe
dominati qui depuis 18 mois s'est
beaucoup impliqué dans ce dossier et qui
a fait la preuve de toute sa capacité
des côtes et qui nous a permis de bien
cheminée pour établir un texte de
première lecture qui a je crois pouvoir
le dire
structurer le débat autour de ce projet
de loi
qu'il me soit permis aussi de redire
notre conviction que la commission
spéciale était la bonne organisation et
car nous avons pu intégrer au sein de
cette commission les préoccupations des
quatre commissions et qui était
compétente en ce domaine pour une partie
chacune du champ de ce texte
et grâce à cela grâce à nos débats
internes aux consultations auxquelles
nous avons procédé aux tables rondes
en particulier nous avons pu faire
prévaloir un certain équilibre entre
nous l'assemblée nationale a fait un
choix organique différent et il me
semble mais pardonnez moi de ne pas être
complètement objectif que le mode
d'organisation du sénat et sur ce sujet
pour un texte concernant à la fois les
lois les affaires économiques les
finances les affaires sociales le choix
organique du sénat a été probablement le
plus efficace et le plus porteur
d'innovation
une seconde observation
en ce qui concerne le coeur même de nos
travaux et ces derniers ont reposé sur
la participation active des membres de
la commission
quelle que soit leur sensibilité
politique
chaque groupe c'est vraiment très bien
impliqué dans l'élaboration de ce texte
et ceci nous permet au delà bien sûr des
attitudes politiques qui sont très
légitimement les nôtres de nous
constituer ce que je qualifierais de
patrimoine commun il ya bien un sens
qu'un socle commun dans lequel nous
pouvons les uns et les autres nous
reconnaître cela peut s'expliquer sans
doute par la conjugaison des
préoccupations gouvernementales et de
celles que reflétait les initiatives
parlementaires qui s'étaient exprimés et
que philippe dominati a bien voulu citer
il est clair que pour la plupart d'entre
nous nous sommes excédés par ce que nous
voyons dans nos départements par la
pression de la concurrence
l'insistance de publicité tapageuse qui
pousse à l'erreur bon nombre de nos
administrés et en particulier parmi les
plus fragiles il était donc urgent de
réformer le système en profondeur et
c'est ce que nous avons fait ce
sentiment de l'urgence d'ailleurs nous
conduit aujourd'hui à souhaiter qu'il
soit mis un point final au débat
on aurait pu aller plus loin on pourrait
encore améliorer bien des choses mais le
souci de l'efficacité
celui de l'urgence sociale vont nous
conduire à souhaiter que le sénat adopte
le texte tel qu'il nous parvient de
l'assemblée nationale et nous nous en
justifieront bien sûr lors de la
discussion des articles ce texte
en effet me paraît équilibré il réforme
en profondeur le modèle économique du
crédit à la consommation
pour autant il ne casse pas la dynamique
de ce secteur et je crois que nous
sommes parvenus par les ajouts réalisé
en première lecture
ajout auxquels s'additionnent ceux de
l'assemblée nationale à atteindre cet
équilibre les aspects les plus novateurs
vous les connaissez mes chers collègues
c'est la réforme du régime de l'usure
régime faure ancien et auxquels il a
fallu réfléchir et pour lequel il a
fallu définir une nouvelle approche
cela pouvait faire peur quand on a en
quelque sorte ouvert ce ce sujet mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il peut vraiment y
avoir consensus autour de la solution à
laquelle nous avons travaillé en commun
avec le gouvernement second aspect
novateur c'est la perspective de
création d'un fichier positif sujet ô
combien conflictuelle voir passionnel
lors de la préparation des débats de
première lecture j'ai la faiblesse de
croire madame le ministre que la formule
équilibrée
launay de transactions que nous avions
conseillé en première lecture a permis
de dépassionner les choses de prendre du
temps d'accepter de portée
un regard pluraliste sur ce sujet en
troisième lieu et vous avez bien voulu
le souligner ainsi que philippe dominati
nous avons souhaité préciser la place du
microcrédit personnel dans tout ce
paysage n'en reste pas moins que les
dispositions sans doute les plus
visibles
celle qui marque le parcours du
consommateur avec lequel nous avons
cheminé madame le ministre lors de votre
intervention
et ce sont des dispositions comme
l'encadrement de la distribution du
crédit sur le lieu de vente
la limitation du crédit renouvelable à
ce que doit être son objet réel
c'est-à-dire un besoin de trésorerie
ponctuelles et tout ceci devant
permettre de lutter contre le mal
endettement des ménages
de la même façon nos apports concrets
sont l'exigence de la double offre de
crédit la mise en place dans les
surfaces de vente d' espace dédié la
formation des personnels et qui
travaillent et le renforcement des
informations à délivrer aux emprunteurs
tout ceci s'ajoutant au paiement
comptant par défaut et au remboursement
minimum du capital à chaque échéance
voilà un modèle global qui est clair qui
doit répondre aux difficultés auxquelles
nous étions confrontés qui doit être de
nature à réduire les tentations
excessive et qui conduisait
beaucoup de nos concitoyens sur le
chemin du surendettement par le mal
endettement
bref un modèle auquel les opérateurs
vont pouvoir se conformer sans qu'il en
résulte de rupture de leur activité tout
ceci étant dit madame le ministre
et je souhaiterais terminer par ce
sentiment d'urgence qui implique une
sortie rapide des textes d'application
30 mesures d'application sont prévus le
calendrier législatif la rareté du temps
parlementaire nous ont conduits à
attendre un an pour pouvoir nous
prononcer définitivement sur ce projet
de loi mais il est clair et vous nous
l'avez indiqué tout à l'heure que ceux
ci et ne doit pas conduire à de nouveaux
délais pour la mise en oeuvre
administratives pour la sortie des
textes d'application du moins par de
nouveaux délais et qu'ils ne soient pas
réduits à ce qui est strictement requis
par l'élaboration et la mise en forme de
ces textes
vous nous avez donc parler de six mois
pour l'ensemble de ces dispositions
je peux vous dire vous imaginez bien que
nous serons les uns et les autres
très vigilant sur cet aspect des choses
et car nous avons le sentiment que
beaucoup de nos collègues sont en
attente et les associations de
consommateurs sans doute encore
davantage
donc madame la ministre madame le
ministre et en saluant votre engagement
personnel en la matière
et en vous remerciant d'avoir précisé
ces échéances je souhaite que vos
services et l'ensemble des services de
l'état concernés par cette affaire se
mobilisent et des des deux mains pour
que les délais que vous avez fixé soit
parfaitement respecté mes chers
collègues
la commission spéciale vous appelle
naturellement à suivre les avis qui
seront exprimés en son nom par le
rapporteur philippe dominati est donc
vous invitera à voter le texte tel qu'il
nous parvient dans la version qui a été
arrêté par l'assemblée nationale
merci monsieur le président de la
commission spéciale dans la suite de la
discussion générale
la parole est à madame nathalie goulet
au titre de l'union centriste mais le
président mam le ministre mes chers
collègues le texte que nous examiné en
deuxième lecture répond à un vrai besoin
avec des moyens appropriés et osons le
dire c'est assez rare en ces rondes dans
les temps législatif que nous traversons
il peut sûrement être encore améliorée
mais enfin c'est déjà une avancée
considérable
c'est donc sans surprise que je vous
dirais l'adhésion du groupe centriste
auquel je suis rattaché le mien propre
et puisque nous sommes entre nous on
peut le dire je vais vous faire une
confidence à la mort de mon père il ya
quelques années ma soeur et moi avons dû
faire le point de la situation
financière de mes parents nous avons
découvert un gros dossier comportant un
certain nombre de sous dossiers qui
étaient autant de contrats de découverte
et de crédit autres revolving et bien
que capitalisant à nous deux à un niveau
bac + 16
nous avons eu beaucoup de difficultés à
nous y retrouver et donc muni de ciseaux
à céret nous avons passé a longuement à
couper les cartes en deux ce qui nous a
semblé le seul moyen d'arrêter
l'hémorragie c'est donc évidemment avec
beaucoup d'intérêt que le teint
ce qui nous est proposé répondra je
pense à cette situation de complexité
qui font que les gens cumulent des
cartes en espèces d'accordéon dans leur
portefeuille les chiffres sont
accablants en 2009 le nombre de ménages
surendettés a augmenté de plus de 20%
par rapport à l'année précédente
près de 190 mille personnes
principalement les classes moyennes sont
touchés par ce surendettement les plans
d'étalement de la date s'étire sur 10
ans pour un montant moyen de 40000 euros
ce montant a augmenté de 25% en trois
ans contre 20 milles en allemagne et 18
mille en belgique
au total les procédures de
rétablissement personnel pour 2009
représente 1,3 milliard d'euros cette
énorme
les causes de surendettement sont connus
trop de crédit le taux moyen en france
est de 19,3 en basse-normandie 10.3 la
mauvaise gestion basse normandie
donc ma région 7,8 le la région qui
comporte le plus de taux de mauvaise
gestion et je regrette vraiment que
michel charasse nous ait quittés c'est
l'auvergne avec 14 9 % licenciement le
taux national est de 26,5 l'alsace 28,8
la basse-normandie 25.5 cet énorme
séparation divorce d'as des ressources
accidents maladies et décès sont les
causes principalement répertorié à ce
point de mon intervention je rappellerai
les propositions de muguette dini et de
claude biver qui sont aujourd'hui des
propositions qui figurent dans le projet
de loi mais je voudrais profiter de
cette tribune pour évoquer deux sujets
le premier concerne les cessions de
créances des différents organismes de
crédit et j'ai un exemple récent ayant
reçu un courrier de réclamation pour une
somme actualisée de 1200 euros
une créances réclamées par une officine
de recouvrement au nom d'hôtel était le
cofinoga se fit carte cetelem donc dès
le premier courrier j'ai joint
l'officine en lui demandant des
justificatifs la réponse que j'ai obtenu
c'est comment comptez vous régler
j'ai argumenté en expliquant que je ne
voyais pas d'où provenait cette créance
ou cette dette est impossible de
recevoir le moindre justificatif m'a
répondu ça d'officine le dossier est
archivé et donc devant mon refus
d'obtempérer j'ai reçu un appel
provenant très probablement d'une de ses
plates formes de traitement à l'étranger
m'indiquant qu'il fallait prendre un
avocat pour des archives et un dossier
dont on demandait le paiement cette
affaire personnelle ne présente
strictement aucun intérêt sauf à
réfléchir au contrôle et à la
réglementation
dans le cas des cessions de créances le
débiteur cd devrait savoir acquis là
c'est en récréant ccd c'est le minimum
et je suis persuadé qu'en cette matière
les marges de progression sont
nombreuses car si je suis assez
imperméable par habitude et par
profession au lettre d'huissier des
personnes âgées ou fragiles peuvent se
retrouver encore plus fragilisés voire
abuser peut-être devrait-on réfléchir
également à le problème de la
prescription
il serait intéressant madame le ministre
d'avoir votre avis sur la question
l'autre sujet concerne le secteur
agricole car personne dans cet hémicycle
n'a oublié madame la ministre que vous
avez aussi été ministre de l'agriculture
et de la pêche
la situation des agriculteurs comme des
artisans d'ailleurs dont la situation
personnelle et professionnelle sont très
imbriqué leur interdit la voie à la
commission de surendettement
or au moment de la crise agricole frappe
très durement le secteur laitier
notamment et où il va falloir
accompagner beaucoup d'agriculteurs
valeur sortie il faudrait vraiment
trouver une solution adaptée
en effet de nombreux agriculteurs
exercent sans nom propre et de ce point
de vue se ressemblent sur pardon se
retrouvent dans des situations de
particuliers il faut rappeler que 12 %
des emplois bas normands sont liées à
l'agriculture 59000 équivalents temps
plein la région basse normandie à hop
organisé la semaine dernière à
l'initiative de son président laurent
beauvais les assises de l'urgence
agricole excellent président les
constats des établissements bancaires
rejoints par ceux de la chambre
d'agriculture l'institut de l'élevage
l'association de gestion cer france
atteste des situations financières
extrêmement dégradée diagnostiquant que
20 % des exploitations ne pourront pas
traverser la crise
les encours dégradé représente une
augmentation de 65% par rapport à 2009
et l'activité de crédit de trésorerie a
augmenté de 200% pour le crédit agricole
en un an
il va donc sans dire que la carte
dressée par le crédit agricole des taux
d' encours douteux litigieux par agence
est particulièrement inquiétant pour le
département de l'orne le sud du perche
cher transformer en luberon mais quand
même et une partie du pays d'auge
comporte 30 % des exploitations qui
présente elle même une situation nette
négative
la situation de surendettement des
agriculteurs et non seulement
professionnelle mais également
personnelle et je pense qu'il serait
souhaitable qu'une solution d'ensemble
puisse leur être proposées en
coopération avec les chambres et
l'ensemble des services administratifs
et fiscaux et naturellement avec votre
collègue de l'agriculture et de la pêche
d'autant qu'ils sont soumis eux aussi à
des pratiques de démarchage notamment
pour des intrants du matériel agricole
qui fait l'objet nous le savons tous
d'une concurrence entre les
exploitations pour ne pas dire entre les
exploitants eux-mêmes ces matériels sont
très chères sont utilisés quelques
semaines par an et ils constituent des
investissements très lourds financé par
les vendeurs eux-mêmes
il serait sans doute précieux de pouvoir
travailler sur une certaine déontologie
en la matière s'agissant de pratique
moins connus mais tout aussi existantes
de démarchage peut-être pourrions-nous
même le ministre instaurée dans chaque
préfecture une réunion mensuelle comme
celle qui existe pour le financement de
l'économie
uniquement réservé aux questions
agricoles qui comporterait outre les
banques chambre d'agriculture les
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles les
jeunes agriculteurs ainsi que les
représentants non syndiqués je pense
particulièrement à l'appli j'en aurai
terminé madame le ministre en vous
réitérant le soutien du groupe auquel
j'appartiens pour ce texte
comme il me reste 7 minutes non il fera
7 minutes ont trois minutes
do trente-et-une alors comme le
rapporteur avait cité le guépard dans le
rapport du la loi de finances j'ai une
envie folle de profiter de cette tribune
en citant un clan des siciliens une
célèbre formule de alain delon respecte
répondant à jean gabin une envie folle
voilà ça se respecte
je profite de la minute qu'ils meurent
as madame le ministre puisque nous
venons de parler des plus fragiles
d'entre nous de vous dire combien nous
sommes heureux d'avoir voté la
suppression du dic
dans le cadre de la récente loi de
finances ce ne sont pas les images
absolument inadmissible du week-end qui
me démentiront les sommes ainsi
économisées seront bien mieux utilisé
par les clubs amateurs et je vous
remercie madame le ministre d'avoir revu
votre position pour la loi de finances
2010 sur ce sujet ne pouvons que rendre
hommage à votre lucidité
merci mme asha collègues la parole est à
madame nicole bricq au titre du parti
socialiste groupe socialiste pardon
même la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur philippe dominati
monsieur le président de la commission
spéciale mes chers collègues
voici un texte qui déposait en conseil
des ministres le 22 avril 2009 débattu
au sénat en première lecture le 16 juin
de la même année a dû attendre le 24
mars 2010 pour être examiné par
l'assemblée nationale qu'il a finalement
voté le 27 avril le gouvernement et sa
majorité ont donc pris leur temps pour
légiférer sur une réforme à laquelle
madame la ministre vous avez à plusieurs
reprises proclamé votre attachement et
pour laquelle vous avez déclaré être
vous êtes le plus totalement engagé le
gouvernement nous a habitués à plus de
célérité dans les textes dont la porte
était pourtant d'ampleur alors qu'ils
eussent justifier d'un examen attentif
du parlement précisément un délai aussi
long se justifie t'il par l'ampleur de
la réforme du crédit à la consommation
qui est la question que nous nous sommes
posée à l'orée de cette deuxième lecture
et bien du point de vue de notre groupe
le groupe socialiste la réponse est
négative et ce d'autant plus que le
texte pourrait appliquer dans sa
totalité doit faire l'objet de pas moins
de trente décret en effet si l'assemblée
nationale a apporté de nombreuses
modifications voire même des articles
nouveaux dont je reparlerai
elle n'a pas modifié substantiellement
l'économie de l'offre de crédit à la
consommation elle n'a pas pas plus que
la première lecture du sénat mise en
place les mesures préventives pour
restreindre les cas de surendettement
alors madame la ministre tout à l'heure
je vous ai écouté avec attention vous
avez utilisé des éléments de langage
c'est très bien pour le 13h de france 2
mais ici nous faisons la loi nous sommes
au parlement il ne faudrait pas trompé
des centaines de milliers de gens qui
ont recours au crédit à la consommation
et dont certains d'entre eux se
retrouvent à la fin du cycle empêtré
dans les commissions de surendettement
il ne faudrait pas que l'emballage
trompe sur la réalité
donc si bien de la réalité dont nous
allons parler dans le peu de temps qui
nous est accordée si j'ai bien compris
et en effet s'agissant du serait
nettement on sait d'après les dernières
statistiques connues que dans 90% des
cas
on y retrouve l'effet cumulatif des
crédits renouvelables qu'on peut
qualifier de subprimes à la française
or de 2008 à 2009 on a insisté à la fois
une explosion due
nombre de dossiers et de leur montant
moyen évalué à 41 mille euros est à la
fois parallèlement à un durcissement de
l'attitude des prêteurs qui craignent
pour leurs risques dans les commissions
de surendettement à une typologie plus
lourde des dossiers présentés car tout
comme l'état les ménages ont recours au
crédit pour leurs dépenses courantes
enfin en regard du nombre de dossiers à
traiter par les commissions les
difficultés de fonctionnement de
celles-ci sont manifestes sans qu'il y
soit porté remède
je veux ici rappeler notre attachement à
opérer une réforme profonde du crédit à
la consommation que nous avons défendu
en première lecture sans ans retrouvé
l'empreinte en deuxième lecture
notre insistance s'appuie sur quatre
piliers premièrement il s'agit pour nous
de satisfaire à la demande claire et
partagée par toutes les associations de
consommateurs à savoir la séparation
nette et entière de la carte de crédit
et de la carte de fidélité
elle ne sera pas satisfaite à la fin de
la très courte navette parlementaire et
sera toujours source de confusions
préjudiciables aux seuls emprunteurs
permettre aux consommateurs de choisir
entre crédit amortissable et crédit
renouvelable au delà d'un seuil n'est
pas de nature à modifier la demande si
l'emprunteur ne sais pas qui
l'empruntent
qui plus est à un taux excessif ni
l'assemblée ni la majorité sénatoriale
ne tienne compte du rapport de la cour
des comptes remis au début de l'année
2010 qui recommande d'interdire ces
cartes qu'elle qualifie de confuse et
qui propose dans ses recommandations
tenant compte de l'examen en cours de
notre texte que si les mesures prises
dans ce texte s'avère inefficace et bien
la cour des comptes recommande
d'interdire ces cartes dès que ces
cartes qui confuses comme elle les
qualifie
le deuxième point et c'est un sujet de
discordance avec majorité et
gouvernement et a trait à le taux de
l'usure
finalement à la fin de cette très courte
navette parlementaire même si la durée
d'examen a été longue
nous n'aurons pas franchi le cap décisif
concernant le taux de l'usure il s'est
tenu la semaine dernière à lyon un
colloque ou des magistrats spécialiste
du surendettement se sont exprimés j'en
cite je citerai l'un d'eux qu'il nous
dit le plus efficace
or et été de baisser par la loi le taux
de l'usure actuellement fixée par les
banques en fonction des taux maximum
pratiqués pour inciter les prêteurs à se
montrer plus vigilants pour éviter les
impayés
ce pas vous n'avez pas voulu le franchir
notre proposition qui consiste à lier le
taux auquel allié le taux de l'usure à
celui auquel les banques se refinancent
est particulièrement adapté à la période
où elles le font à un très bas coût il
n'est en effet pas question d'oublier
que les banques répugnent à prendre des
risques tout en bénéficiant du soutien
de la puissance publique qu'elle soit
celle des états en europe ou celle de la
banque centrale européenne c'est un
paradoxe que nous n'acceptons pas
d'autant plus que nous sommes sceptiques
sur l'application de la loi par les
banquiers
ainsi le numéro hors-série de
juillet-août 2010 de 60 millions de
consommateurs relève que l'obligation
d'informer l'emprunteur de la variation
dans le temps du taux d'intérêt d'un
crédit renouvelable
bien qu ex créé qu'inscrite dans la loi
c'est l'article l311 10 du code de la
consommation n'est pas respectée il a
fallu un arrêt de la cour d'appel de pau
en date du 24 septembre 2009 pour le
rappeler
troisième sujet où nous marquons notre
désaccord il est pour nous essentiel
vous ne modifiez pas l'économie générale
d'un crédit à la consommation en
maintenant quoi que vous en disiez la
prééminence du crédit renouvelable sur
le crédit simple que constitue le prêt
personnel
nous avions défendu en première lecture
le crédit personnel remboursables
immédiatement pour un montant modique
maximum de 3000 euros qui correspond le
mieux à la demande des foyers modestes
nous l'avions appelé crédit social nous
avions proposé de redéposer cet
amendement mais comme je le dis dans mon
rappel au règlement il a été déclaré
irrecevable au titre de l'application
intégrale et littérale de notre
règlement intérieur
depuis lors depuis que nous avons
débattu de cette proposition
les banques ont beaucoup communiqué
autour de ce qu'elle nomme microcrédit
en s'engageant sur les objectifs
chiffrés jusqu'en 2011
elles ont distribué 5520 microcrédit
personnel en 2009 d'après les sources de
la caisse de dépôts et consignations qui
gère le fonds de cohésion sociale dont
je reparlerai tout à l'heure c'est une
offre marginal est lié à la présence
d'un accompagnement social du demandeur
ce faisant les banques ne font que
reprendre l'initiative menée par les
collectivités locales au travers des
crédits municipaux
c'est certainement utile mais ce n'est
pas de nature à peser sur l'offre de
crédit aux ménages
je veux parler des foyers modestes ceux
qui travaillent plus pour gagner souvent
- ainsi que les jeunes qui ne trouvent
pas de place dans la vie active sans
pour autant bénéficier d'un
accompagnement social
quatrièmement le malgré le temps passé
entre les deux lectures nous n'avons
toujours pas l'assurance que soit mise
en place monsieur le rapporteur a
fichier positif la prudence initiale de
la majorité sénatoriale qui avait laissé
une marge de latitude à la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale n'a rencontré chez
celles-ci qu un modeste gain de temps
qui n'annule pas le délai d'examen de la
loi du reste puisque on a quand même
perdu plus d'un an et en définitive
seguin ce petit gain de temps aboutira
seulement à vérifier les conditions de
la faisabilité du la mise en place d'un
fichier positif le fait que le comité de
préfiguration remette son rapport plus
rapidement ne lève pas le doute donc sur
la mise en place d'un tel fichier
l'imprécision du texte que nous ne
pourrons pas réexaminé au fond contenu
du souhait d'arriver au vote conforme et
bien elle exigera forcément une nouvelle
loi si même la faisabilité était avérée
parce que il faudra respecter les
recommandations de la cnil
donc il y aura donc un report signer dié
de sa création
pourtant le fichier positif est un moyen
décisif pour éviter aux emprunteurs
excusez l'expression de plongée ce qui
est encore pire de replonger dans le
surendettement
j'en veux pour preuve que l'association
française des usagers bancaires l'afub
qui n'était pas la plus emballés à la
création de ce fichier positif
souhaitent qu'au-delà du rachat de cinq
crédits renouvelables par un nouveau
prêt un tel fichier puisse être
actionnés pourquoi parceque ils ont
constaté que les rachats de crédits et
bien ceux qui ont pouvaient en
bénéficier
on les retrouve et dans les commissions
de surendettement deux ou trois ans
après encore faudrait-il pour utiliser
une telle recommandation de
l'association française des usagers de
banque qu'il existe à ce fichier tel
n'est pas le cas je voudrais aussi
souligner que la commission spéciale n'a
pas souhaité amendé le texte qui nous
arrive de de l'assemblée nationale j'en
conclus donc que majorité et
gouvernement veulent un vote conforme
c'est pas très compliqué d'arriver à
cette conclusion mais aucune raison
sérieuse n'est avancée pour y avoir
recours quand il s'agit du sort de
centaines de milliers de gens ni
l'encombrement du khalife du calendrier
parlementaire ni
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président madame la ministre le respect
des délais donnés pour la mise en oeuvre
de la directive ne se ne saurait
justifier ce vote conforme parce que
s'agissant du respect des délais
concernant la mise en oeuvre des
directives
je pourrais vous citer des exemples où
la france se situe résolument en dehors
des clous de la commission si vous me
permettez cette expression vous
féliciter madame la ministre de ne pas
avoir demandé l'urgence sur ce texte
mais la méthode du vote conforme revient
au même elle bride votre majorité elle
dissout le débat public et elle parce
que l'opposition est impuissante à faire
valoir ses arguments et surtout à avoir
un débat qui permette de faire avancer
sinon le texte mais de le faire avancer
dans son application elle éclaire ce
débat est clair quand même les juges qui
ont quand même un rôle important à jouer
dans la manie dans la matière dont nous
traitons pourtant moi je regrette cette
précipitation en fin de parcours
bon même si j'ai bien compris madame la
ministre que vous voulez accroché à
votre costume la médaille de ce texte
car il a une portée sociale et ce n'est
pas votre terrain habituel puisque on
vous voit plus plus souvent à la
télévision dans les sommets
internationaux et nous savons quelle
place vous y occuper pourtant nous avons
observé que l'assemblée nationale a
apporté de nombreuses modifications dont
certaines ne respecte ni l'esprit ni la
lettre de la lecture sénatoriales je
citerai deux exemples la modification
apportée à l'article 1er qui donne au
comité de suivi chargé de surveiller les
marges des établissements bancaires un
caractère provisoire limitée à deux ans
certains députés auraient même voulu le
supprimer les banques peuvent prendre
des risques avec des produits dérivés
dangereux mais avec les ménages elles
peuvent prendre des marges bien au delà
de leurs risques c'est un comble je
rappelle qu'un très personnelle modique
supporter un taux d'intérêt qu'il ne
l'est pas deuxième exemple
l'affaiblissement du dispositif
sénatoriales encadrant la publicité par
la modification apportée par les députés
à l'article 2 s'agissant d'un autre
exemple d'une autre nature le
microcrédit personnel l'assemblée
nationale en a élargi le champ défini
par le sénat on peut penser que les
interventions du fonds de cohésion
sociale seront donc à l'avenir plus
importante
or j'ai regardé les chiffres le montant
du fonds de cohésion sociale a diminuées
à partir de 2008 alors qu'il avait fait
l'objet d'une programmation
pluriannuelle lors de sa création en
2005 la discussion approfondie aurait au
moins permis de donner une indication au
gouvernement en vue d'en tirer la
conséquence pour la loi de finances pour
2009 pour le 2011 pardon il n'en sera
rien pour conclure je voudrais déploré
que le sénat se prive de donner un avis
motivé sur les novations introduite par
l'assemblée dont l'une m'apparaît d'une
motivation et d'une efficacité douteuse
et l'autre inacceptable dans sa forme et
mériterait au moins un examen sur le
fond il s'agit pour la première de
l'article 5 bis à nouveau introduit par
les députés qui obligera les officiers
d'état civil
à lire aux futurs époux l'article 220 du
code civil relatif à leurs engagements
contractuels en matière de dépenses du
ménage
la solide en la solennité du mariage en
prend un rude coup j'imagine que pour un
tel acte de bravoure l'assemblée
nationale à consulter les associations
d'élus les maires et les élus qui
procède au mariage apprécieront sans
doute de ce rajout qui est qui est
complètement qui est assez ridicule il
faut quand même le dire
alors il s'agit pour la deuxième
remarque de l'introduction d'un morceau
de réformes institutionnelles
c'est l'article 35 qui traite d'une
nouvelle organisation des institutions
publiques de la consommation qui vise à
placer sous la responsabilité du
directeur de l'insee trois institutions
la commission de la sécurité des
consommateurs la commission des clauses
abusives ainsi que la commission de la
médiation de la consommation
alors bon je vais pas jusqu'à dire que
c'est un cavalier
mais on est tellement habitué maintenant
à ce que le gouvernement c'est un
amendement du gouvernement par morceaux
dans des tests qui ne sont pas faits
pour sa place des bouts de réforme que
je voulais le signaler alors on avance
la motivation habituel il faut
mutualiser mais toutefois ces
commissions garderaient leur
personnalité morale et leur président ce
qui ne te rends tu ne rassure personne
la commission spéciale sans votre examen
se contente d'affirmer qu'il y aura
ainsi des synergies réel sans se donner
les moyens d'en vérifier l'existence et
se satisfait des dires du gouvernement
qui affirme vouloir développer la
médiation au moins pourrait-on disposer
d'un bilan de la médiation dans les
domaines où elle s'exerce déjà quels
qu'en soient les tensions cette
procédure n'est pas la garantie pour les
consommateurs d'obtenir réparation des
préjudices commerciaux toujours plus
nombreux qu'ils subissent nous en
reparlerons madame la ministre ait
prochainement
jeudi 24 juin c'est à dire cette semaine
quand avec mon groupe je défendrai notre
proposition de loi visant à introduire
en droit français la procédure de
recours collectif en tout état de cause
il n'est pas normal que le savez le
sénat accepte cette modification sans en
débattre vous voulez donc un vote
conforme qui écourte la navette qui
évite la commission mixte paritaire
nous défendrons nos amendements sans
illusion mais avec conviction et le
rapporteur nous a évité lors de la tenue
de la commission spéciale à vouloir
soumettre je reprends votre expression
le texte à l'épreuve de la réalité
eh bien je pense que celle ci nous
donnera raison merci leurs collègues
la parole est à madame anne marie
escoffier pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
spéciale et monsieur président de la
commission spéciale mes chers collègues
il ya un an notre assemblée a adopté en
première lecture un projet de loi
portant réforme du crédit à la
consommation
après un passage à l'assemblée nationale
ce texte
économiquement urgent et socialement
prioritaires s'est enrichi leu
disposition aussi innovante que diverses
bien entendu l'objet principal demeure
puisqu'il s'agit de mieux encadrer les
conditions d'accès au crédit de mieux
protéger les consommateurs et de
responsabiliser davantage les
professionnels du crédit
je rappellerai juste les chiffres qui
ont déjà été dit 14 millions de français
font appel au crédit à la consommation 9
millions au crédit renouvelable et parmi
eux plus de 213 me dépose chaque année
un dossier de surendettement soit un
taux d'augmentation de plus de 18 %
entre 2008 et 2009
en effet non seulement le nombre de nos
concitoyens surendettée va croissant
mais cette tendance socio économique
s'accompagne d'un phénomène de
paupérisation de banalisation
particulièrement dangereux différentes
études laissent à penser que ce jour
plus de 7 millions de personnes c'est à
dire 15 % de la population serait
insolvable depuis plusieurs années les
associations de consommateurs alertent
régulièrement les pouvoirs publics sur
les véritables pièges financiers dont
nombre de nos compatriotes sont victimes
le vieil adage qui voulait que jadis on
ne prête qu'aux riches et désormais
contredit puisque ce sont bien les plus
pauvres ou les plus fragiles qui sont
endettés
ce constat dressé nous devons bien
admettre que le remède législatif à un
tel fléau a tardé à venir et nous ne
pouvons que le regretter
devant l'ampleur d'un phénomène allant
jusqu à saper les bases de la société
contemporaine
et un dispositif législatif devenu
inopérant le sénat en première lecture
n'est pas demeuré inerte loin s'en faut
et a enrichi le texte initialement
proposé par le gouvernement en y
important des exigences d'encadrement du
crédit accru et une plus grande
protection des ménages les plus exposés
aux risques liés à l'endettement le
crédit à la consommation bien utilisé et
légitime et mérite toute l'attention du
législateur
le sénat pour la seconde fois devra y
apporter toute sa force pour rendre ce
texte encore plus efficace pour
améliorer la vie quotidienne de nos
compatriotes
rappelons que dans son rapport annuel de
2010 la cour des comptes affirme que la
politique française de lutte contre le
surendettement est déséquilibré le
dispositif légal visant à traiter la
situation individuelle des surendettés
plutôt qu'à prévenir le surendettement
toutefois l'enjeu fondamental de notre
débat de cette réforme a trait à
l'évaluation de la solvabilité de
l'emprunteur contracter un crédit est un
engagement non seulement pour
l'emprunteur mais aussi pour le prêteur
il faut privilégier une coresponsabilité
ation des deux acteurs du prêt on voit
bien trop souvent des organismes peu
regardants accorder des crédits à des
personnes dont la situation financière
n'offrent manifestement aucune garantie
de remboursement
dès lors le fichier national de
l'endettement se justifie et a toute sa
place
comment ne pas adhérer à l'esprit même
des dispositions proposées qui devrait
avoir pour effet non pas de tarir le
crédit à la consommation ce qui serait
une très grave erreur mais de le
maîtriser avec l'apport de nouvelles
mesures adopté au sénat puis à
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi
privilégie l'accès à un crédit
responsable
faisons une part véritable
formation du consommateur plusieurs
dispositions auront une portée véritable
je pense notamment à l'allongement du
délai de rétractation à la séparation
des destinations de la carte de fidélité
ou au remboursement imposé d'une partie
du capital
autant de mesures dont les familles
françaises pourront bénéficier
rapidement
en tout cas je l'espère en première
lecture
mon groupe avait proposé trois
amendements que le sénat a adopté afin
de renforcer l'information du prêteur à
l'emprunteur je me félicite que
l'assemblée nationale est maintenu en
l'état le premier amendement et
conserver l'esprit des deux autres en
dépit de quelques modifications
rédactionnelles bien entendu les progrès
apportés par le texte demanderont à être
vérifiée au quotidien et sur le terrain
soulignons également l'amélioration
introduite par le texte dans le
fonctionnement des commissions de
surendettement dispositions qui
devraient permettre à ces commissions
d'accélérer les processus d'examen des
dossiers et de prendre des décisions
relevant jusqu'à présent de la
compétence du juge cette mesure de
simplification des procédures ne peut
que favoriser le règlement de dossiers
souvent difficile tout en veillant à
l'accompagnement des personnes
fragilisées par leur situation
financière
il est grand temps que grâce au
renforcement des règles applicables en
matière de publicité
qu'il s'agisse des encarts publiés dans
les magazines de programmes tv ou des
publicités objet de mailing ils ne
soient dorénavant plus possible de faire
croire aux consommateurs que le recours
au crédit peut améliorer sa situation
financière
le renforcement des conditions
d'obtention d'un crédit par le biais
d'une vérification accrue et
systématique de la solvabilité de
l'emprunteur devrait contribuer à
limiter les cas de surendettement
les prêteurs
ne doivent plus échapper à leurs
responsabilités concernant le taux de
l'usure les dispositifs adopté en
première lecture
même s'ils peuvent ne pas paraître tout
à fait satisfaisant permettent
d'accroître l'attractivité du crédit
amortissable et de réduire la part du
crédit renouvelable
l'examen du texte sur le crédit à la
consommation se poursuit au sénat
christine lagarde la ministre de
l'économie esther son adoption avant
elle la fin de l'année christine lagarde
justement qui a exprimé son souhait de
publier tous les décrets concernant le
texte avant la fin de l'année lé mesure
entrerait ainsi en vigueur selon un
calendrier à très précis ce serait en
septembre pour les mesures concernant la
publicité et le microcrédit en novembre
pour toutes les mesures concernant le
surendettement et en mai 2011 pour ce
qui concerne le crédit renouvelable tout
de suite retrouvé votre journal de 18h
présenter atteint michel grossiord est
très bonne soirée